MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Jason!
What's the weather
like in London?
JASON BERRYMAN: Well,
Martin, it's the UK,
so of course it's
raining outside.
How about you?
How's your weather
in California?
MARTIN OMANDER: You know, I've
had the curtains drawn all day
because I'm recording videos,
so I really don't know.
But today, we're
talking about how
to coordinate microservices.
Is it better to have a central
coordinator-- orchestration--
or is it better
for control to be
distributed among the
services-- choreography?
JASON BERRYMAN: Well, with
so many things in life,
it depends.
I'd be happy to share
what I've learned
from a recent large project.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Thanks for
joining me on the show, Jason.
You're a freelance Google
Cloud architect at 418.dev?
JASON BERRYMAN:
Yes, that's right.
I'm also a Google Developers
expert for both Firebase
and Google Cloud platform,
and I run the Google Developer
group in Milton Keynes,
which is just outside London.
MARTIN OMANDER: Nice.
I love Google Developer groups.
They're great places for
meeting other developers
and learning from each other.
Now, you're helping your
parking company in the UK
build their system on top of
Google Cloud platform, right?
JASON BERRYMAN: Yes.
The company collects vehicle
movement and parking permit
data from car parks
and motorway services.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
And what is that data used for?
JASON BERRYMAN: They use the
data with serverless Google
Cloud products to provide
analytics and metrics
to their customers.
The data can also be used
for parking enforcement.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ooh, you
mentioned serverless.
I love that stuff.
Why did they pick serverless?
JASON BERRYMAN: They're
using serverless
so that they can focus
their engineering
hours on new
feature development,
and to minimize the operations
work for their running systems.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
Now there are two ways of
coordinating microservices.
Orchestration-- a
central coordinator
calls all the microservices
in the right order,
or choreography--
microservices send and receive
events and act on them,
so control is distributed.
Which one did you pick for
the parking company, Jason?
JASON BERRYMAN: Well, each
one has particular strengths
and weaknesses.
So we used both.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm.
Tell me more about that.
JASON BERRYMAN:
Well, for example,
when a car enters a
parking lot, a camera
takes a picture of
their license plate.
The picture of the
vehicle going in
gets matched with the picture
of the vehicle going out.
And that matched visit then gets
linked to one or more parking
permits.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm, that
sounds kind of complicated.
JASON BERRYMAN: Yes.
And to make it simpler, we have
multiple services, each one
doing part of the work.
So for example, we've
got one service which
ingests the data
from the cameras
and passes it through the
visit-matching service,
then another one which
ingests the permit data
and matches it with the visits.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
Now, how do you
coordinate these services?
I imagine the camera
ingestion service
needs to let the matching
service know that a vehicle has
entered or exited?
JASON BERRYMAN: Well,
we use orchestration,
where a central controller
calls a series of services
in a pipeline and
returns a result.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
That sounds pretty
straightforward.
It's nice to have control of
the business logic in one place,
right?
JASON BERRYMAN: Yes.
But sometimes,
that isn't optimal.
We are using a NoSQL
document database
that is optimized for reads.
So we can sometimes
need to normalize data.
For example, an administrator
may update the expiry date
for a whole group
of parking permits.
If the expiry date
has been extended,
a visit that was
beyond the expiry date
may now be within it.
So the driver shouldn't have to
pay a parking penalty charge.
MARTIN OMANDER: Everyone hates
paying parking penalties,
especially if their
permit was just extended.
Now, how do you prevent that?
JASON BERRYMAN: When the
permit group is updated,
we trigger updates of all
the permits in that group.
This, in turn,
means that we have
to match the permits
against the visits again.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
But why can't you use a
central coordinator for this?
JASON BERRYMAN: If we
only want to change
the expiry date
of one permit, we
don't need to update
any other permits--
we only need to trigger
the visit-matching again.
A central coordinator
would become very complex
if it should be able to handle
both updates to many permits
and updates just to
individual permits.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, I see.
So if you don't
use orchestration,
what do you use instead?
JASON BERRYMAN: Then we use
the other method, choreography,
where each service
receives messages,
takes action on those
messages, and sends
new messages to
the other services.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
in what situations
do you pick orchestration,
and when do you
pick choreography instead?
JASON BERRYMAN: When the
process is always the same,
orchestration shines.
For example, when a
car enters, we always
save the raw camera data.
The data is transformed from
each camera's manufactured,
proprietary format to
our standard data format.
And then we extract
the images from that
and save them into
Google Cloud Storage.
Finally, we send the event data
to Cloud Pub/Sub for processing
further down the pipeline.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That makes sense.
And when do you
use choreography?
JASON BERRYMAN: When
we have services
which may form
part of a workflow,
but may also be
triggered individually.
A good example is the
permit group scenario
we talked about earlier.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
Now, it sounds like
choreography is
based on having many triggers.
Is it messy to have lots of
triggers all over the system?
How do you manage
that complexity?
JASON BERRYMAN: If you're using
Cloud Functions or Cloud Run
services directly
in Google Cloud,
it's really essential to
maintain good documentation
and use a tool like Deployment
Manager or Terraform
to deploy them.
However, if you're using
the Firebase suite,
it's much easier to
develop, test, and deploy
your Cloud Functions.
There's even a great
local emulator.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Does that mean that you
prefer to use Cloud Functions
for Firebase all the time?
JASON BERRYMAN: Cloud Functions
for Firebase only support
Node.js and TypeScript, which
is great for web developers,
but if your team uses
another language--
such as Go or Python--
it may not be such a great fit.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
And which Google
products do you recommend
for orchestration and for
choreography, respectively?
JASON BERRYMAN: For
orchestration, Workflows
is a great product for designing
orchestration pipelines.
Workflows can be triggered
by other services,
such as Cloud Functions,
Cloud Run, or Cloud Scheduler.
For choreography,
you can use Eventarc
to trigger individual Cloud
Run or Cloud Function services,
based on individual events.
However, there
are some services,
like Cloud Firestore
and Cloud Storage,
which can trigger Cloud
Functions directly
without Eventarc,
whenever an event happens.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
And to recap, when
would you recommend
using orchestration versus
a choreography architecture?
JASON BERRYMAN: If
you're developing
a traditional n-tier
system on Google Cloud,
it's probably best to use
the orchestration model.
However, if you're
building a user
interface-focused
application with something
like the Firebase suite, this is
where choreography works really
well.
However, there may
be times that you
need to create a hybrid
app, in which case,
you can leverage the
best of both worlds.
MARTIN OMANDER: The
best of both worlds--
I like that.
Thank you for joining
me and sharing
your real-world
experience, Jason.
JASON BERRYMAN: Happy to do it.
MARTIN OMANDER: And thank
you, everyone, for watching.
If you have any questions
for Jason or me,
add a comment below.
Also, let me know if there are
other serverless topics you'd
like to see in future episodes.
Bye for now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]